[Música]
y en directo a Vamos hasta la capital
peruana con nuestro corresponsal
Francisco Zacarías quien tiene detalles
sobre las 11 investigaciones abiertas
por la fiscalía por las muertes
relacionadas con las protestas que han
sacudido al país desde diciembre Así es
como buenas noches cuéntenos Cómo puede
afectar esto al gobierno de Dina
boluarte
Buenas noches alguno euristas señalan
que esto afecta seriamente tanto a la
presidenta Dina boluarte al Primer
Ministro Alberto tarola como a los
ministros del interior y defensa quienes
ya están siendo investigados por el
Ministerio Público en los presuntos
delitos de genocidio homicidio
calificado y graves lesiones la fiscalía
contabiliza 54 muertos y 793 personas
heridas pero hay que señalar que este no
es el único desafío que debe afrontar el
gobierno de Tina boluarte en el
parlamento debe encarar una acusación
constitucional por presuntas violaciones
a los Derechos Humanos debido a las
muertes ocurridas en el sur del Perú y
si es que esto no es suficiente un grupo
de congresistas de izquierda está
impulsando una moción de impeachment
contra Dina boluarte que pide su
incapacidad moral permanente y para que
esta moción de vacancia presidencial
surge efecto se requieren 66 votos de
los 130 congresistas
de Perú Francisco de otro lado el
congreso declaró como persona no grata
al expresidente boliviano Evo Morales A
qué se debe esta decisión
para el parlamento peruano las
declaraciones del expresidente boliviano
Evo Morales sobre la política peruana y
sus constantes intervenciones buscan
incitar y desintegrar al orden interno
en especial en el sur del Perú es por
eso que en mayoría con 74 votos el
parlamento de este país declaró personas
no ingrata a Evo Morales y en la misma
iniciativa que le pide al
superintendencia Nacional de migraciones
que impida el ingreso de Morales por la
Fronteras del Perú hay que señalar por
otro lado que la presidenta Dina
boluarte denunció este miércoles al
grupo indígena los ponchos rojos que
están relacionados al ex mandatario
boliviano Morales de ser quienes
ilegalmente habrían ingresado armas y
municiones al sur del Perú en esa línea
la mandataria peruana señaló que con
esas armas murieron muchos indígenas el
último de enero Durante los
enfrentamientos entre la policía y los
manifestantes Dina boluarte en ese
sentido le ha pedido a la fiscalía de
este país una profunda investigación
para esclarecer estos sucesos